these are things I read and I go I can't
believe this you decided to take a six-
week acting class like in England or
something and uh you go out and your
teacher ends up being Alan Rickman who
Hans from Die Hard who's one of the best
he was one of the greatest actors ever
but that guy Alan Rickman turns to you
and goes are you thinking of being a
professional actor and you go I don't
know I don't know what I'm going to do
maybe I'll go back to school he says no
you're good you should be a professional
actor what a [__] moment right yeah
now that was a big deal for me yeah we
got to love that guy no totally that guy
was the nicest guy he was great singles
you make out with a girl in a scene they
hired my girlfriend to do it I said one
word in that movie what I just say what
that's all I say and it was [__] hard
it was really hard yeah cuz it was like
and the guy just had me do it over and
over and over again and it was like it's
just hard I'm like what do I do with one
word and you're trying to put everything
into that and you overdo it is the
problem you start overdoing it whereas
you have all these words you can spread
it out you can relax but you just you
overdo you overact a lot of the time
when you have too few words must have
been amazing to be around that set of
singles though did you like kind of hang
out any even though you were doing man
you know like a a kissing scene with
your girlfriend I mean yeah yeah it was
great yeah that was Cameron Crow right I
mean wow talk about a legendary guy
totally and all those actors they were
all great actors it was great I mean
every time I went on to a set it was it
was great cuz I didn't know what the
hell was going on I was learning so much
that I was happy to be doing whatever
when you're one line is what do you
still go to the premiere or do they just
like they don't even invite you no don't
think
I I'm the guy who says what if anybody
uh no I remember going and seeing it
finally in a theater and sitting there I
think with my girlfriend at the time and
that moment came up in the people and I
turn around I go what and the woman in
front of me in the theater goes like
that really like like shitty acting what
I don't know she just went like that I
was like I want look at that guy he's
not hot at all what's he doing yeah I
was like really oh God did she break up
with you after that my girlfriend no she
stuck with me for a while she stuck with
me you know what else was a role you had
like that when you played man in
sleeping bag on NYPD Blue yes that was
particularly hard we were shooting in an
actual
squatter's Village Under The Manhattan
Bridge so there was that in the first
place which was crazy and it's funny cuz
you're surrounded by a lot of these kind
of homeless guys and a lot of them were
sag a lot of them had a sag card because
they played this kind of thing in movies
all the time and that was they were
professional homeless people they were
professional homeless people and that
was good but I remembered being proud of
myself cuz I felt like I really got into
that part in the right way because I I
went off to go get some you know
something at the craft service or a cup
of coffee or something and coming back
the pa the the kid running the set
wouldn't let me back on set cuz he
thought I was an actual homeless guy and
I remember thinking that's then I'm
getting this right I'm getting man and
sleeping bag right
yeah